Switching gears, I was excited, also,
because when you say numbers
and your passion and I get so intimidated by numbers.
Don't be.
Oh, gosh. All right, well, help me.
'Cause I read some things
and I wanna have you share 'em with everybody.
We're gonna give us five interest,
we, you, are gonna give us five interesting tips
on saving money and investing.
All right, are you ready?
Yep.
Okay. Rent.
We have to pay it.
Housing is what we, you know,
have to pay on a monthly basis.
But you can get ahead
if you can pay six to 12 months of your rent up front.
So you don't have to be stressed
about paying your rent on a monthly basis.
Okay, travel.
You want to go to Florida?
You want to go to somewhere warm?
Go during the off season.
Off season, the rental prices are a lot cheaper.
The weather in Miami is still great.
And you're not around a lot of people,
which I think during COVID was, you know, was everything.
All right.
Entertainment, TV subscriptions, our viewing habits,
our indulgences.
Tips for that?
You don't have to pay for it all on your own.
You have friends, family, get into a pot.
Have someone pay
for one subscription platform and the other.
Because, as we know, there's so many nowadays.
It just offsets the cost so much.
Gym membership?
Cut it.
(audience laughs)
Just cut it. We don't need it.
(audience claps and cheers)
And finally, let's say you wanna attempt investing.
This is where I get completely intimidated.
So I'm really excited to learn from you.
Start with $20. Teach.
Yes, $20.
Investing is not as intimidating
as I think a lot of people want to believe.
When you go to the grocery store, think about it.
You're picking up different brands.
Why do you choose those different brands?
Because you've done your research.
You stand by the company. You stand by the product.
Investing is the exact same way.
And now there are so many platforms
that provide trading-free commission
where it's no charge to invest your $20.
So you invest your $20
into a company where you understand the company,
you understand your why, and you go from there.
It's a lot easier than I think people make it out to be.
Are there certains and gambles?
Yeah, so another thing, when it comes to investing,
understanding your risk tolerance.
Your risk tolerance is gonna dictate how you invest.
So if you are someone who gambles
you have a high risk tolerance
and you're probably most likely investing
in new digital currencies, such as crypto.
If you're someone who is a little bit more conservative,
you are investing in high-yield savings accounts,
because that will, nothing will happen to your money.
It will grow a little bit.
But you know that your money is parked and it is safe.
Well, thank you, Lauren.
(audience claps)
I love getting you to talk about this stuff with you.
It's so insightful.
Lauren, you can learn even more from Lauren
on her amazing show, Going Public, on entrepreneur.com.
We will be right back.